c'est parti pour trois kilomètres de
course
pas question de traîner pour ces sept
jeunes polyhandicapés leurs
accompagnants venu ce matin d'un centre
de cergy pontoise
le sport est pour eux un moyen de se
relier au monde extérieur
ça permet aux résidants d'être comme
nous dans le monde dans la société et
donc par de participer à ce qui existe
dans les communes et puis c'est
important aussi pour les professionnels
de pouvoir être eux aussi dans une
dynamique d'inclusion pas facile de
pousser les fauteuils en courant alors
chacun à travailler sa technique à une
ou deux mains
malgré la chaleur les équipes ont su
garder le rythme avec une moyenne des 10
km heure sur tout le parcours
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de raison
d'isoler le handicap du reste de la vie
et en fait nous mettons en avant le
sport à travers le sport est aussi pour
les valides mais c'est aussi une
activité pour les handicapés et c'est ce
que nous voulons mettre en valeur à
l'arrivée joie et soulagement pour tout
le monde les premiers ont franchi la
ligne après 14 minutes de course
les suivants ce sont battus jusqu'au
bout encouragé par le public
avec le succès des jeux paralympiques
les organisateurs espèrent attirer un
plus grand nombre de coureurs et de
public l'an prochain